welcome to this video playing wim
revenger from Russian Ekaterina be
unique yeah she was much higher rated to
for something yes I have played her with
a much higher rating ok very very quick
Bishop g5 against the modern let's see
if I can immediately use this gaining
gaining some some play here time to tell
what very strange stuff
it looks like isn't something this looks
very loose Queen a5 check Bishop b2 b6
probably bishops III very weird stuff
Wow okay I'll just take it this is very
strange Smith Maura with night only to
and Bishop 1g5 and this is just the pole
up for white or black how is she
developing her King side yeah I need you
need to do some some kind of drastic
drastic measures but I'm trying what I'm
trying to do is to play without castles
kill
Knight g4 maybe a bit less nilus know as
Queen a form but I can I can threaten
that 94 now as an idea yeah she
prevented that but now I'm trying to
quickly get play on the C file maybe 95
c4 or just be five yeah why not be five
actually could could be interesting okay
not necessarily night before the special
be five okay not not spending too much
time one way to really get into trouble
again in this game is to to use up far
too much time this position is good for
black anyway I mean its own i justjust I
should just play good enough okay can I
take probably not what about Bishop
takes g4 Bishop g4 takes 94 now that's
it's it's very dangerous
hmm okay it's interesting let's let's
get ahead you have maybe a three is the
real problem but I know she's not really
reacting I'm just ah what the heck yeah
that's that's a great line what I
calculated he has really good stuff I
thought Bishop g4 takes 94-94 Bishop
takes a two I wanted to to use the
bishop twice yeah that's cute and
absolutely absolutely wrong veronic not
working at all ah yeah yeah well if what
else I mean yeah okay even even without
the bishop I probably need to play that
and I want now castleton
or should I just I should take first the
bishop on the light on will be here is
hanging and this is the problem really
check it's hanging huh check this is why
I couldn't fly qui takes a two and now
just Knight c3 ah what the Oh beep yeah
what what I am I look and the piece down
right for how many porns four pawns no
check yeah and she's not even she's just
trying to make me probably with good
reason but I'm not sure this is really
necessary yeah probably it's also
winning but it looks a bit strange to do
that what hmm well 26 a queen a to Queen
a one I mean I'm just giving a ton of
checks but well my queen only am i king
on yet maybe even Queen d6 winning
maybe maybe check um ok now I understand
standard a bit better Luke check the
look check but still rookie one king of
826 King g7 of fig if she gives a check
King age six g5 check I'm going to to h5
and it's no mate its nomad check check I
can go to age six check g5 check King
age five and there is no maid that's not
even a checking and if it takes takes I
can I have some I have some checks here
check HERE king queen Quincy for I this
is actually ok cool I'm back in the game
oh how ridiculous is that completely
undeserved check ok checking I mean now
she's rejecting but luckily this is this
is available and now yeah
Prince III desk night a to check winning
the Queen just everything's working
nicely kingly to is made probably she
just needs to go back what check I'll
take that I'm just better now check I
can take them okay now i can take check
maybe i should have should have gotten
rid of the the beep on while I still
have the chance
very tricky to play for both sides but I
have to have this two pawns this is
quite something check can you have three
now or just push it check check ah time
warning check check check check check
check check check check check mate wow
wow what a game yeah was one of those 00
games where both sides deserve to lose
you know I'm basically winning out of
the opening but Jen then just completely
screw up things by playing this this
simply simply ridiculous Bishop takes g4
I was simply forgetting that I'm
sacrificing the bishop so if you imagine
this position with the bishop on e6 I
can take a 2 and win and well but but
once once i'm here what am I supposed to
play I mean this is at least exposes the
King a bit but check its of course
completely lost and here any move check
my taking probably wins as well but
Bishop c4 for example covering a 2 i'm a
rookie and a piece down check you know i
mean this ok of course you can you can
second play
again Bishop c4 protecting a to check
into this chess wins as well I made into
ah made into wow I mean how lucky can
you be I even overlooked us in the game
between age six check what I want you to
need to show that bridge check check
check Wow check yeah this check yet
clear ended things rather quickly check
aim and this is still winning and the
mate again I made I didn't check Queen
III as the mate Queen Jeffrey King here
check check ing five year of course the
others this exposes the King enough to
like to get to a maid check check this
kind of this kind of play ok and and
this cat this is a draw while this
losses she can just play here and i only
have a perpetual check i don't i cannot
i cannot win check maybe maybe here she
saw some some ghost but there's no when
I mean I can just I can just check this
perpetual check and be really glad to
draw but um yellow Quincy three just
down check just loses and I should play
here before this is much better getting
rid of this pawn and something like this
King moves and here this should win
relatively easily making sure that he
that right doesn't have a pawn him wow
what a roller coaster ride thanks for
watching